I work in the European external Action
Service as a Ukraine desk in the
division on Eastern Partnership I work
for the European external Action Service
in the Western Balkans division for the
moment mostly I'm following everything
which is related to negotiations of the
new eu-ukraine association agreement we
actually as a European external Action
Service since the entry into force of
the Lisbon Treaty we hold the presidency
the permanent presidency of these
working parties
so in fact we chaired these meetings on
a permanent basis as it used to do the
rotating presidency we're in contact
with with Member States diplomats with
diplomats from the countries of the
region we are taking care of like for
example Ukraine who are interested but
also the US mission working here in
Brussels is interested what is the
policy of the EU towards Ukraine as they
are closely following that I have a
diploma in European business
administration it's a double diploma
that I finished in in London and I
started in Madrid after that I
specialized in in foreign trade I
studied at the European University
Vienna in Frankfurt under order which is
the german polish project with and I
started cultural science and at the same
time I did international relations at
the University of Rods off because I'm
half Polish half German so I tried to do
a dual educational system in that time
pre-accession country Poland and in
Germany immediately after I completed my
diploma I applied for an internship in
the Commission so that was my first
experience with the institutions that
didn't lead immediately to do a job as
an official but it was an experience
that I enjoyed and I really appreciate
it I started in process working in the
European Parliament as a political
assistant to an MEP at a member of the
European Parliament and which is a
political job and it depends on the
career and the political reelection of
the member of the European Parliament at
that time I've been already focusing on
on Foreign Relations and especially on
enlargement a neighbourhood policy with
a focus on Turkey
and after having passed the conqueror
for the institution's
to become official a function ere I
joined the Commission in the field of
foreign relation which was in line with
my interest which I had earlier so I've
been very lucky of obtaining that part
which was now transferred to the
European external Action Service
I took a contract with the the
delegation of the European Commission in
Moscow where I dealt with technical
assistance projects and then in in that
particular time I took my exams and once
I have passed the exams I was invited to
take a job in in Brussels as part of the
office of the personal representative of
the High Representative of the time
javier solana in the Western Balkans I
had had very very good experiences of
working closely very closely with women
with Member States which is very
important and which we do not forget
when when dealing with with with
external action and for example I
accompanied recently Member States to a
field trip to Montenegro and we had all
sort of very high-level political
meetings from the president of the
country to the prime minister to the
Foreign Affairs Minister to the
Secretary of State and and that was also
very rewarding because this this
particular area of the world looks at
the U with with with with admiration and
with a with a sincere desire to be part
of our project and I think that's that's
very rewarding but I also very much
enjoyed actually going directly to the
country and going on mission and to meet
the people the local people who were
present early meet our counterparts from
the ministries of Foreign Affairs of the
country and to actually understand
better what the situation on the ground
is the style context helps you a lot
especially in negotiations to understand
the position to understand their fears
or to understand why they are asking
their questions they are asking during
our negotiations those meetings that we
spent with the United Nations for
example were very important in some
you felt really part of the European
Union project as regards negotiations I
was traveling mostly once a month to
Ukraine or Moldova and sometimes we
travel to just trust up to the European
Parliament in order to debrief
colleagues on the state of play where we
are this is the frequent and I've been
yes in Ukraine and Moldova and I'm going
to Georgia soon so which is quite
interesting I've been to many many
places and I feel very lucky that I have
been I have had the opportunity through
my job to get to know places that would
have been difficult to to visit
otherwise I've spent like four I
remember for example a couple of weeks
in in Togo working on specific projects
I've been to Australia and New Zealand
on unimportant multilateral meetings
representing the European Union and I've
been to South America and to the States
so that that's that's that's been
certainly an incredible opportunity of
my job every traditional diplomatic
service has the idea of having people
work both in headquarters and on the
ground in a in an embassy or in our case
in you delegation I think people who are
not open to that might prefer to choose
another part of the EU institutions than
working on foreign relation I think this
is one of the efforts to have the
possibility to go and work abroad to
understand really the country we are
developing new policies for
working language in our department is
almost exclusively English obviously you
use language like your own mother tanks
which is for my case polish and German
when you talk to colleagues from member
states and I've been studying in French
so this language is also used however
negotiations as our negotiations are
contacted half partly in English or in
Ukrainian it is very very good for me
with my polish background and having
learned Russian to understand Ukrainian
I use French and English currently in my
job this is important I mean not only
important is its necessary for anybody
working in external relations French and
English are the two working languages in
fact in our meetings with member states
there's no interpretation a contrary to
other areas of work in the field of
External Relations there is this
agreement that at working level working
group level at least French and English
are equally already at the same level
and they can be used equally
the international working environment is
one of the most attractive aspects of of
my work here and actually I'm very proud
of of having made the decision to work
here
is it still rewarding it's extremely
exciting I enjoy it very much and also
because of my personal background
because I'm German polish so it is
something which I always wanted to be
first of all European and then perhaps
German or polish